foreign
officers and those members of the public
that are joining us this evening on
youtube
for this full council meeting on the
13th of june
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence
yes chad four apologies councillor
woodhouse councillor hackett councillor
watson and councillor cottle hunkin
thank you sandra
item two is to agree the uh potential
minutes of the 11th of april and the agm
on the 16th of may
i'll take the
11th of april meeting first and this is
on
pages four
page five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten 11
12
13
14
and 15.
all in favor
for your show
[Music]
legal standpoint the 101 we don't want
to discuss it never has been the feast
on beaver but actually you'll be glad to
know they are discussing it and not a
global level it's never been dealt with
by due process i'd like to see it proven
to me it's going through the due process
the country's been involved
then we come on to the agn minutes of
the
agm of the 16th of may
so page 16 17
18
19
20 21
22
23
24
25
page 26
so
right
[Music]
three obsessions thank you
okay next item on the agenda is the
action list which is paid 27
speakers item five decorations of
interest we all know the score there if
there are anything on the agenda at
least one item comes up
item six is agreement the gender item
part one and two the arnold part two
item seven to consider correspondence or
other business especially broke forward
around the direction of the chair i've
only got one item which
[Music]
there's been
suggestions that we should move back
into town hall particularly for our
subcommittee meetings like plumbing etc
i understand that tom is preparing a
paper
to which is looking into the the i.t
capability of moving back in the table i
think uh that's going to be reported
back at the
uh to leadership to the leadership kenya
so as soon as that is possible i think
there certainly is a feeling that we
would like to move back into the tunnel
particularly for all subcommittees
whether we actually get back there for
um full council meetings we'll have to
wait for to see what report actually
comes back from
[Music]
my debate consider items uh questions uh
submitter procedural room a9 questions
have been submitted okay
there are no petitions
i'm moving swiftly on item 10
which is the leveling up from the
submission for torridge ages 28 to 41
and chris fuller is going to present
this report chris
people here
and chair we'd like to find no view
presentations provide more detailed
updates
on the proposed ecuador maritime
innovation center building on the call
report
this is a fast-moving piece of work not
only to ensure that we're ready for the
funding date to the leveling up fund by
july 6th but also to deliver on the
funding already secured for project
development through the canoe community
renewal fund in the autumn of 2021.
next thank you
as many of you have no doubt visited the
site
at middle dock is in a beautiful
location
but is frankly in a poor state of repair
it's used as a parking depot for the
waste and recycling fleet does not in
any way maximize its economic or in fact
social potential
significant work has been undertaken
already to ensure the proposed apple
door clean maritime innovation center
most definitely does
next slide
i think it's
crucial to reference from the outset
that the proposals for middle dot and
the outdoor clean and maritime
innovation center
do not stand in isolation
but provide platforms to build an
existing work across northern devon and
across the wider devon or as a future
anchor for proposed activities
the smart biosphere uh being led by the
biosphere foundation is leading the
world the way globally in the field of
blue environmental intelligence
working with partners such as siemens
amazon web services
the satellite systems catapult
government innovation body
uh met office and the environment agency
some incredibly high level partners were
highly committed to work in northern
delhi
this data science industry was a huge
growth opportunity which both the
biosphere foundation and the university
of germany are keen to progress through
the ecuador clean maritime innovation
center
it's also an example of an industry
where a large amount of work can be
undertaken from anywhere in the world
with a computer opening doors for
locations such as apple
and touristy council also recently
published the floating offshore wind
opportunity study
working alongside the hearthstone
southwest lab devon county council and
north dakota council to ensure that we
capitalize planning opportunities and
manage the associated risks of the
proposed floating offshore winds in the
celtic sea
the onshoring of that energy energy with
over six gigawatts potentially different
connections uh in the pipeline for
within turrage provides huge avenues for
high energy sector growth in particular
around delivery of uh uk hydrogen
strategy in an area such as ours of high
fuel poverty
that's an opportunity that really does
present opportunities for future social
journalism in our area
as well as economic opportunities
and finally in terms of localized
opportunities
we also have the resurgence of wolf
and its proximity does create huge
clustering attention
that said it's also enormously important
to emphasize
that the outdoor clean maritime
innovation center
creates
significant
economic and growth opportunities for
businesses across the region with
businesses already being having been
highlighted in great torrington in
bradworthy
and even in weekly
so it's definitely not just about
the businesses that are right on the
doorstep of this proposed center
the university of plymouth and the
university of exeter both fully on board
with proposals which
for me is immensely exciting
frustratingly uh
we're still
[Music]
as i'm sure you'll understand waiting
for some of the sign offs from those
universal partners to fully talk about
uh all of the details that they are keen
to progress and all the activity they're
keen to do on site so we will look to
add those layers in advance on the
fourth of july when we return for full
sign-up for on full council
however it's also crucial this work will
also create wider skills benefits across
the region
from the increased range of maritime
focus courses to be offered by petra
through to a desire to increase relevant
courses at a bit of a college and even
moving towards the commissioning of
educational materials to support local
primary schools
head teachers in biddeford bay at both
primary and secondary levels have been
engaged with and are universally
supportive
and with our comms team developing
materials to be shared in the
full-coming future and in the form of
newsletters to parents to make sure
that parents are aware of the
opportunity and how they can support
to create some real buzz
as part of it as a [ __ ]
this next slide just um shows you a
little bit about the actual
proposal for the
facility and you can see there on the
right hand side of the screen
the the notional section through the
site um this is as if you were standing
um at nyuki street looking towards the
heart of the world shipyard and you can
see the general form there that
facilitates a broad wide access to a new
waterfront
[Music]
key wall
with the
main structure backing onto
the
the road and access to first floor level
where the offices and
research facilities will be directly
from road level
you can also see that we're utilizing
existing retaining structures and
bolstering that with new piled
foundations for the
new
building and then the red
wall
the left-hand side is the new
key wall to straighten up the existing
key wall which is basically
um in three sections that are not fully
aligned so we're looking to unify that
with a single length of about 100 meters
of keysight frontage
and all of that obviously
translates into the mixed-use
accommodation with workshop space
directly accessible from the keysight
level and then high quality office and
research research space in the um
accommodation above
next slide please tom
this uh this diagram is really it's not
it's not a true uh floor plan it's
basically a schedule of adjacencies that
show the relationships between the
various occupiers and their shared
spaces
we have
on the bottom of the diagram there the
the
level one which is the dock level
straight into the workshops and
technical spaces
including the retention of the existing
historic
stone ship building
[Music]
on the right hand side there showing
green
that that is currently proposed for
some agriculture tanks and then above
that um we have um as i explained on the
sections the office accommodation and
labs and technical space
with
a top level of
higher end
space for shared facilities
and also
[Music]
third-party
external sort of business support that
are looking to take up space at that
upper level
so that um
that represents the
general arrangement for the
accommodation and the areas that we've
been working up it is very much
work in progress at the moment because
what we're trying to do is work around
the various
areas and
the income that will be generated from
those to make sure that the economic
model stacks up and so
we are we are nearly there um in terms
of what the actual shape and function
will look like for all of those areas
but it's very much a case of
flexing those to make the best of the
economic model which the
the economic team are working on in
parallel with our cost consultants
so um that's uh
that's basically
the general arrangement the ultimate aid
being to have maximum flexibility and
permeability through the site
so that we can design in some future
proofing as this this center will evolve
over time and obviously
a linkage to the adjacent
high should go
next slide please
this is um
an infographic if you like of what what
the general
space will look like
if you can imagine the entrance is on
the right hand side of that image
from newquay street that that entrance
is being widened
to create improved visibility and also
access an egress from the site for
vehicles that will be delivering
components to the facility
we've got the wide
frontage directly off of the new key
wall
and then the two main
blocks
the left-hand block
being the university of exeter
clean maritime
[Music]
center the center being
the
research space and
plymouth university
education development and agriculture
facilities and then the stone barn on
the right
for the actual
aquaculture tanks
it is very much representative at the
moment obviously the final design is
to be developed in the months ahead as
we take this forward to full plan
um
i'll hand back to chris now just to talk
a little bit about some of the
comparable work
next slide please
[Music]
to make sure that we are developing this
in the right lines we've made sure that
throughout working with experts you've
got relevant experience uh in these
projects obviously turric does not have
experience of delivering
maritime innovation centers or
innovation centres overall so we need to
make sure that we're bringing our
expertise
in the architects for example that we've
been working with uh
recently forever the last
few years delivered the iaero
center
for roads developments up in yeovil
trinity's trinity david's is a recent
opening which is the institute for
advanced automated propulsion at the
university of bath so given the clean
maritime propulsion elements being
proposed by the university of exeter
there's a clear overlap there to make
sure that we get the facilities right
so they're well versed in terms of
these sorts of
mixed facilities we've also been working
with the economist who developed the
operational modeling
for again i aero
and
the node innovation center as they've
been required
we need to make sure that when we're
developing new plans that we're looking
constantly at the commercial viability
center uh
and ensuring that the centre actually
has a positive benefit to tourist
district council as well as to tourist
districts
um than creating a negative side
next slide this time
i think this slide very much speaks for
itself
but unless we provide a catalyst to
create change
creating growth opportunities and
driving skills growth
will continue to face these changes
the figure for me here that 41 of jobs
in torridge currently pay the loan
living wage
truly demonstrates the need for
intervention and impact
which is where it's very pleasing that
the work that's been done so far
demonstrates that
the
proposals that we're bringing forward
currently have a
benefit cost ratio of well over the two
to one
that
is required to get through the gateway
requirements
so that really is demonstrating that it
sort of on the economic side stands to
have a huge impact and that's before you
start layering in the social elements
and the impact on aspiration for our
next generation
next
again
we're fully aware
of the
risks that any development process
entails and have been featuring
those right to the heart of our work to
make sure that at every step
we're mitigating where possible
as i said
we've worked with experts with an
established track record and who also
embedded in these
issues making sure that
they're taking for example
issues around
construction cost inflation ongoing
material supply challenges and also the
difficulties around procurement into
normal devon
firmly in mind rather than going off on
a flight of fantasy that's not then
deliverable
we've also been working hard to maintain
uh strong partner relationships
and bring ever more partners
into that process
we've had the two marine events at
petrov both last november and last may
which have brought over 120 different
businesses and public sector
organizations
into the conversation and so we've had
significant opportunities to sense check
and to engage with those partners and
those businesses to make sure that the
direction of travel on this is
absolutely on the roller is on the right
lines
and that's
actually ramping up now as we're in a
position to start talking more publicly
about the center so during the last two
days i've already had conversations with
three different businesses uh on this
all of whom have said that they're very
keen to take up both workshop workshop
and office space
all the sector engagement has indicated
that actually the issue
will be not being able to provide enough
space
in this
next
so effectively and this will be
returning on the fourth of july to full
council for the full sign-off before the
bid submission on the 6th of july
however we're very much seeing that big
submission as just
uh
away marker
in order to be able to deliver this
within the funding uh time scales of
uh leveling that fund on the 31st of
march 2025 for leveling up spending and
we are fully intending to to press on
and make sure that we
progress the science further with the
architects we have funding in place to
achieve that
[Music]
making sure that we're in a strong
position so that when hopefully there is
a positive family announcement in autumn
that we're ready again just to get
cracking and continue moving forward
[Music]
which would be the last name brings me
to the end of the
presentation you very much chris thank
you adrian for that presentation our
little vote required on this is
obviously just for members information
but um there are any questions that
anyone would like to ask
sorry i think council goes on his hand
up first
[Music]
wouldn't have
[Music]
the other question is that
the shipyard i presume also only
decide where they fit out
their ships
is there a neighbor in between or is
that totally
in the ownership of the ship
there's a building
[Music]
valuable
the gap between the shipyard and this
development because there's a slipway
runs down there a public slip line is
that we're referring to no no
ships that's obviously in their
ownership
is there any ship about ours or is there
a
sort of slip way where they're used to
fields
no not that one
this this where you can see on your
picture here and everything after that
we truly are going to be working in
partnership
[Music]
so it's a very good question chair
and
it's one that we did look at initially
um as part of the options for the
entrance to the site um i think we came
up with with three possible alternatives
the one at the southern end was
preferred in terms of bringing vehicles
into the site
as you come directly
off of the road
near to the end of south road but
unfortunately when you
actually profile the site and the
topography and general gradients and
difference in height between the road
level at that point and the docker level
um the gradient of access wrap that
would be required would basically mean
that we would be eating up far too much
of the developable area of the site and
that would significantly compromise the
overall
space that we can achieve and obviously
get income from
and there's another
factor to
consider as well and that is the
remodeling an existing entrance is far
more straightforward than getting
approvals for a brand new entrance so
we've
basically come up with this hybrid of
widening the existing to still achieve
the access requirements without
compromising the overall
loss of
footprint of the site
what we will be doing is providing
pedestrian
access
straight in off of the higher level road
at the end of southwest so that you
as you
arrive at the site and you approach the
site from around the bend you you have a
sense of arrival
in that there will be a frontage and
pedestrian access directly from that and
from that level into what will be level
one which is um you know you know almost
a first floor level above the workshops
thank you very
[Music]
how confident are you that you will
receive that by the fourth of july and
what happens if you don't
i think that
we're very confident that it will come
through and being reassured by
universities on that front um
plymouth university will be given sign
off and there'll be a quote going out
from the vice chancellor
as part of
cons materials with this um
so if excellent don't manage to secure
full commission by that point
we'll still have at least one university
that
will be able to kind of fully submit
with
that says
it's not currently seen as a
higher risk
[Music]
implications is it going to be built
above that and secondly
um i'm just looking at the figures
you've provided i know it's very rough
and ready here but 15 million pounds and
torridge has got to supply 10
um but we're going to include the land
value we've got any idea what the value
of the land is so we've got some idea of
what we're talking about
certainly
i'll answer the first question about the
flooding
first of all if actually if you look at
the photograph that's on the screen at
the moment you can see that the
that is actually pretty much um high
water
and there is a significant
amount of key ward that is still
available from from high water to what
is dark side level
and um the actual
uh
datums that we're working with suggest
that
we're not going to need
any enhancement
for flood defenses along what will be a
working key
that said the design has been obviously
developed to take account of
future
flood risks that
we need to consider for 100 years plus
and the
[Music]
ground
level units are obviously all just
workshop spaces
so that um
that is not
to be a problem at the moment
so
uh
in terms of your second question um site
value was from memory something like 280
000 pounds
that was um
purchase price that'll be factored into
the
overall contribution
so torridge is looking for 1.2 million
is our contribution
[Music]
will really make up a difference for
that
you know so we get the
200 000 for the demand value
so then torridge has to take a public
workshop for the rest of the night
so this is what we'll be returning on
when we earn some returning on fourth of
july um to receive approval
but that's what i mentioned about the
operational movement that's taking place
that has been factored in at various
different levels of uh what the full um
spend will be
at all stages it's making sure that that
interests and payment is then taken into
consideration to make sure
that the centre has fought full
viability
chair thank you um as this i think is
the
first public outing that we've had of
this i i would like to say certainly
that this this is
very exciting very good um and at last
uh oh torridge we have something that
looks like uh fit for for today tomorrow
and the future
and that we're actually plumbing into
um
the very on message area of that this is
looking at uh
it will i mean i suspect that the the
inflow investment level won't be two to
one it might be four to one um because
already and we're you know you're still
at the conceptual stage
already you're getting a vast amount of
interest and i know the amount of
interest that the two universities are
taking into it which is
positively exciting um so
it's really really good to see that at
last we've got something where we're
looking out of the box and we're
actually looking at what is needed on
the thing so to all of those who've been
involved in it um i personally would say
excellent i know the legal and carefree
have been very busy on on it and well
done
this
a limiting factor on this
will be your ability to expand
because actually what you've got there
isn't a lot if this takes off
and all the indications are and the way
that
um
modern business and vote in the
direction that things are going this is
bang on met and therefore everybody is
going to want to get in there um
have you identified
uh
area i don't know that i'm i'm not a bit
of a man or an apple man and so i don't
know the ground that well is there scope
to expand
[Music]
you're quite right there's no skill to
expand on this site it is constrained on
on
all four sides really by existing um
you know
physical limitations of
[Music]
the site
with the highway and waterfront
but there is um obviously an adjacent
season with the north side where there
is fully expected to be expansion
potential by other businesses and
holland and wharf that would be looking
to
obviously grow on the back of this
innovation
and um in discussions with um with sean
i'm sure sharon is here tonight he'd be
saying that the next
generation or iteration of the local
plan will need to be identifying grow on
space within the local plan for business
growth that is specifically centered
around
this topic
and i know that's something that's um
you know very much in his mind in
discussing
with the playing team
well thank you for those
positive comments questions
congratulate chris for his hard work on
this project was extremely exciting
i can see there could be some
constraints which have been hinted at
tonight
you wish to respond question
one important thing that hasn't been
mentioned so far which uh as an epidural
member i think is very important for us
to
speak about is actually the fact that
throughout
we've been planning this uh
in close
liaison with high levels and seeing this
project very much as a buffer zone
um so master planning
both this site and iron and wolvesite to
make sure
that the middle dot proposals are not
seen as a heavy industrial nuisance
to uh the surrounding residents that
this is very much that buffer between
those residential spaces
and
the harlem wolf new key sites so that it
shouldn't be kind of viewed this is a an
industry kind of noisy
uh
sort of
sort of dirt
ridden site this is very technology
driven computers and some kind of
workshop space
that actually
should blend very much
into the site and actually provide
an improved view
for the surrounding residents
and obviously not
have the
waste and recycling lorries leaving at
six o'clock every morning
okay thank you for that everyone
oh sorry got two more hands up that
coach question james you were first win
i don't mind i was just
just i thought i was just going to sum
up a bit um just to thank chris and um
adrian for all the work they've done um
chris touched on the two uh
presentations we've done it petrol or he
did at petrol um claire attended the
first one i attended the second one done
a little bit of opening speech and
asleep saxophone followed me
um i'm not sure that's the way i ordered
but that's how it worked
but the intense interest in the building
the room was full
and the different stuff i was quite
pulled over by all the stuff that goes
with it that can follow on so it really
is when you just look at this it's not
just what you're looking at there's much
much more behind it uh steve and i've
got a meeting with tom hart tomorrow
morning
at um
the ship builders yard in aberdeen um
not so much to discuss things but to
carry on
working together as a council with a
main player in the area
and basically i just was
hoping that culture will fully support
it
because it has been a lot of work it's
very exciting
um
but it does present a huge opportunity
for us so i'd just like to thank chris
and adrian for the work they've done and
also the photograph we did have our mp
stood in the front
and so he's fully on board which is what
you need for these projects these days
you need mp support
so and i think jeffrey's coming back
next week all the week after i lose
track of dance
so yeah i'm just i'm really pretty
engaged and keen on it so thank you
chair thank you that's about again lucky
chair i knew this on page 33 from
agriculture aqua
aqua
culture
is a fish stock involved here in any way
at all because that's you talk about
economic as well as environmental
there's no mention of fish stock here at
all but that is on very close to site
between her in the wolf and his
it's not at this stage but it's very
much featured in uh conversation about
future period options and the future
benefits uh for the fish stock stemming
from
the investment as well
thank you very much chair
okay well as i said earlier this is for
information uh only there's no vote to
be taken uh i think it's a brilliant
presentation and
at least you know members will be kept
up to speed on this exciting development
[Music]
reports
okay
so as members uh recall
in 2019 you just come up to the
microphone
[Music]
right as members will recall in 2019 we
declared a climate emergency committed
the council's reaching net carbon
neutrality by 2030 and this is a very
broad and ever-changing agenda touching
on a wide range of services and
departments across the authority
and in order to be transparent in what
we're doing and trying to achieve we've
committed to reviewing and updating our
carbon environment and biodiversity plan
to bring this back to members on an
annual basis
so the cover report details you update
some changes since uh last year's
submission and this includes
incorporation of the of the carbon
footprint in review and which was
reported to cnr in december last year
and it also includes at the request of
the member climate working group and the
coastal change management area technical
evidence maps in full which highlights
the potential flood risk across our
coastal areas primarily due to the
impacts of climate change and it also
gives an update on a number of wider
projects that will have an impact on our
own plan and such as progress with the
development of the of the county's
carbon plan and the early stages of our
own local plan review
but one of the main changes that members
will notice is around the action plan
that's given at the end of the document
on page 80 of your bundle and we
recognize that we need to provide more
detail on what is probably the main
focus of the plan the the actual actions
and progress and the various elements it
incorporates and we've added more detail
around the potential carbon saving of
each of the projects and a rough
indication of delivery time scales
obviously we're now trying to focus on
the privatization prioritization of
projects against our stated target
and future revisions of the carbon plan
will take this further and in particular
we recognize that we need to provide
more information on potential costs and
funding mechanisms for some of the
projects going forward and to start
looking at this against potential carbon
savings and but this is all works in
progress and in the meantime this plan
has been considered by the member
climbing work climate working group and
who have put forward for approval by
your by yourselves and i'm happy to take
any questions
any questions thank you john
75
76 and 77
he's actually in the report that the the
maps um need to be seen in the in the
context of the um it is worst case
scenario so this is the the impacts
without any
um flood defense works be being carried
out but that is mentioned in the report
which then refers directly to those maps
[Music]
[Music]
please
against
other extensions
[Music]
and i'm one from the coastal house
of christie's first book
thank you
um i assume that all councils report
that we had a presentation uh from the
gentleman called tim steer
about
that was two months ago and he had a
list there of uh
people he was hoping to get on board
since then he's actually got quite a few
people on board
north devon council decided to support
it our mp jeffrey cox has supported it
grant schatz has supported it
and uh
he is incredibly hard working and he's
managed already get five and a half
thousand pounds
pledged to pay for a consultant to draw
out the actual details um it is an
aspiration
um
i realize that and i suspect there are
many problems along the line
along the line
but uh
i hope that um you were impressed with
him i know i was and uh
what he's looking for now is uh
basically support from this council to
match other bodies
um
there are going to be massive problems
we all know that but it is an
aspirational thing and uh he would like
it put in our local plan
there's a joint of the plan in north
devon so
i assume north devon have already agreed
to put in their local plan by voting in
support of them um so i would ask
tonight that uh we also support this
idea
council mechanics
i i'd like to set this motion if but
also
offer an amendment that it's also
embedded in the economic development
plan if that's at all possible
so with that amendment that's also
included in the economic development
plan it's been proposed and seconded of
the show of hands-on support based
and against
mr jones events and abstentions
one abstention comes from the goal
thank you very much
and second there's a motion is from
haynes
um
yes this concerns the minor injury
students have visited hospital which is
as far away as i know not functioning at
the moment
um i don't spend time alone in having
had excellent care in the past from my
religious unit
um it was very convenient um saying
going to barnesville to amd and
waiting for
four hours or well it's the latest even
nine hours isn't it 24 hours
but
a minor injuries unit um
was an excellent facility
and it was promised i think last year or
possibly didn't know that
it was going to be reopened um together
together with the overkill
[Music]
staff off from there to go to boston
nevertheless
it was a vital facility in my view for
local people
in terms of climate etc reduced car
charges
all sorts of reasons so i'm hoping
that this council will write to the nhs
and also helped us modify them
to copy um into jeffrey cox as well
so if this facility is restored
thank you
thank you any comments from anyone
before we i said
well the proposer seconded i might say
very very sensible um motion that has
been suggested and i certainly support
it myself so we're taking advil all in
favor be sure
thank you very much
[Music]
well as we have no popular items
brings us to the end of the week thank
you very much